17 and into the early hours of the 23rd
to those injured to everyone still
struggling
and most importantly to the families of
those who died particularly John's
family
and safi's family
I wish to say this very clearly
you were badly let down on that night
you were entitled to expect much better
from our Emergency Services than the
response provided
and as you have heard from them today
everyone here is truly sorry that did
not happen
of course there were many people who did
act courageously and selflessly in the
moment as Sir John said himself today
we recognize what they did
police officers and paramedics
did run into what they believed to be a
dangerous situation as did Arena staff
travel safe officers and staff from
northern rail at Victoria Station
in particular the members of the public
who helped others in a desperate
situation deserve our huge thanks and
more recognition for what they did
many people in all emergency services
did do their jobs properly
but they were let down
by the lack of a properly organized
response
as the inquiry report makes clear the
reason people were left in this
unacceptable position was the result of
poor Advanced planning and a failure to
follow established guidance for an
incident of this nature
that led to a poorly coordinated and
Confused response operation on the night
there is no justification nor excuse for
this
I can only speak for the services for
which I am responsible great Manchester
police and great Manchester fire and
rescue service
and in my view they failed so badly
because at the time they had poor
leadership
a poor internal culture and an inability
to collaborate properly and apply
gesture principles as the public should
have been expected entitled to expect
back in 2017 it was particularly the
failure of the fire service to respond
on the night which exposed the fact that
something was seriously amidst with the
overall response that was the reason why
the deputy mayor and I decided it would
be wrong to wait for this public inquiry
to conclude and instead we initiated our
own process of inquiry and learning
we asked Lord kerslake to undertake a
non-statutry review so that we could
begin to understand what had happened
and make changes
to our Police Service and our fire
service at the earliest opportunity
I note today that the curse labor report
has been endorsed by the chair of the
inquiry and has been used as a
foundation for today's report
with regard to the fire service the
kersley report in 2018
helped us get quickly
to the scale of the internal problems it
had
which was confirmed by visits to all
fire stations in Greater Munster that
the deputy mayor and I personally
undertook
I can say this with confidence to the
people of Greater Manchester
your fire service of today is not the
fire service of 2017.
it has new more effective leadership
which in turn has brought about an
improvement in internal culture and as
his Majesty's inspectorate of constabury
and Fire and Rescue Services has
confirmed has also improved in the way
the service supports its staff
evidence of this can be seen in the
agreement reached by the new Chief Fire
officer and the fire brigades Union for
a new approach to dealing with a
marauding terrorist attack
great National Fire and Rescue service
is currently training all of its
firefighters to respond in that
eventuality
equipping all points with the capability
and alongside London is the first fire
service in the country to do so
with regards to Greater monster police
what this inquiry reveals is very
troubling
it is barely believable to me given my
request to them to cooperate fully with
the kurzo report that our police force
back then provided an inaccurate account
of their actions nine months after the
attack which was signed off by the
former Chief Constable something which
he accepted in evidence in 2021 was a
quote's grave error
it is my view that the force tried to
stick for too long to a corporate
narrative that suggested it had active
effectively
that wasn't just disrespectful to the
families and those injured
it had the effect of misleading myself
and the deputy man
denied everyone the opportunity to learn
until late the action needed to improve
the force
this is sadly something we have seen in
the aftermath of other disasters and the
pattern that keeps on repeating
in late 2020 I had all the evidence I
needed to change the leadership of
Greater Manchester police and that is
what I did
last week his Majesty's Chief Inspector
of constabury confirmed that there has
been a total turnaround since
so I could also say this with confidence
to the greater much of the public
your police force of today is a very
different entity to what it was in 2017.
but there is no complacency at all
on our part
we will face up fully
to every single word and recommendation
in this report to ensure that the
process of improvement and learning in
both Services continues and the deputy
mayor will say more about this in a
moment
however
I see four
additional substantial actions which are
needed in the light of what has been
revealed today
first
I have asked the new Chief constable and
Chief Fire officer to consider
whether we need a major overhaul of the
handling of 999 calls in Greater
Manchester
while I do not criticize individual
members of Staff it is clear
the Northwest Fire Control did not
adequately support the response on that
night
this has led me to question whether the
arrangement of handling 999 fire calls
in a separate service outside of Greater
Manchester is the right one for us going
forward
particularly when it comes to mounting
the best joint response we can to Major
incidents
therefore I have asked for an evaluation
from both Chiefs on whether we should
co-locate police and fire in a joint
control room in Greater Manchester
I expect to receive that in the new year
and will make a further statement then
second I am clear that this inquiry
provides a major point of reflection and
learning not just for our police force
but indeed for every police force in
England and Wales and public service in
the country
time and again in the aftermath of major
incidents we have seen how Public
Services have failed to tell the truth
at the first time of asking
this doesn't just deny bereaved families
the answers they deserve
which is appalling in itself
it denies those organizations the
opportunity to learn and change
a legal duty of Candor on all public
servants would break this pattern that
keeps on repeating
it would Empower police officers and
public servants at every level
to say what they feel needs to be set to
all official inquiries and thereby
resist any pressure from above not to do
so in that way it will be a protection
against the wrong behaviors that can
lead to poor cultures
it is five years this week since Bishop
James Jones recommended a statutory duty
of Candor in his report on the
experience of the Hillsborough families
given that a previous prime minister
personally commissioned his review I
consider it disrespectful to her
to the Hillsborough families to the
Manchester Arena families and the
grenfell families
that that review has Lane on a white
hole shelf for five full years without
so much as a government response
this cannot continue
I have had a constructive meeting this
week with the new Home Secretary
and I call on her to bring forward a
response as soon as possible and to
accept the need for a statutory duty of
condo
in my view a culture of speaking
candidly is what our new Chief Constable
has brought to Greater Manchester police
it is what has helped us to exit special
measures
and it can do the same for other police
forces as a tool for Learning and
Improvement
but it needs to be enshrined on a
permanent basis
to help if the government would like to
trial its approach I would like to offer
greater Manchester to the Home Secretary
as a place where we would be willing to
do that working in partnership with the
home office
third like Sir John I want to point to
another legislative change which is
needed and if enacted would actually
help the emergency services do their job
this is the duty to protect or Martin's
law
which would strengthen security
Arrangements at public venues big and
small
and create a consistency and Clarity
currently lacking
we pay tribute to Martin's mum vegan
Murray for championing this change
but its implementation is now overdue as
Sir John said
the government must turn commitments to
legislate given to feed him and others
into real action
and resist any calls to water down this
important and much needed law
fourth and finally I want to ensure that
the findings of this authoritative and
important public inquiry
will be protected in perpetuity
and not be allowed to be undermined or
subverted by those who wish to present
false narratives and conspiracies
I find it utterly abhorrent that people
injured in this atrocity and families
bereaved have been harassed and trolled
by those who seek to portray it as a
hoax I can barely believe that something
like this is even happening in a country
like ours
but I have seen also how it is becoming
more common for the victims of this and
other disasters to be on the receiving
end of trolling using false narratives I
call therefore on the government to
consider making it a specific offense to
deny the facts about major disasters
such as the deaths that occurred and to
subvert the findings of non-contestive
inquiries like this creating false
narrasses narratives and conspiracies
which re-traumatize victims
in conclusion over the last five years I
have had the privilege of getting to
know the families who lost loved ones on
that night
they are without exception wonderful
people who as I said at the start
deserve so much better
I have also got to know many of those
injured and have seen firsthand how they
have come together to help each other
through initiatives such as our
incredible survivors choir
I hope they all know me well enough by
now to know that I would never give them
platitudes like lessons will be learned
what I can instead say to them today is
that major changes have already been
made on the back of what happened and
more article
thank you
okay
good afternoon
I know that today will be yet another
traumatic day for the brewery families
the survivors and those close to them
they have endured and continued to
endure the most unimaginable pain
I'm hearing the detail of
today's findings whilst very important
to them
will rehearse yet again their anguish
and their loss and I'm thinking
especially what I've learned today
I joined them out in recognizing the
individual and organizational failures
in the response of our Police and Fire
and Rescue Services on the night of the
Arena attack and I too am truly sorry
for that
when the attack happened the mayor and I
had been imposed for only a couple of
weeks we did not expect that our
Emergency Services there to protect our
communities and save lives could fail in
this catastrophic way
I recognize that the challenges faced by
emergency responders at the sea were
incredibly difficult dealing with
hundreds of casualties in a context of
uncertainty and danger not knowing
whether another shooter existed or there
was another imminent attack planned
those who responded immediately at the
scene professionals and members of the
public alike were heroic and selfless
and I commend them
they did the best they could
while some of our senior commandants
failed them and failed the victims
36 hours after the attack the mayor and
I went to the city room
we talked to the forensic experts in
counter terrorist housing detectives who
had already even by then made
significant progress in securing
evidence from what was a devastating
scene
painstaking investigation that followed
was meticulous as was of support for
families and survivors
the successful extradition and
prosecution of the terrorist brother and
accomplice was a major achievement
however
commendable as all these actions were in
the days months and into years after the
attack they can't eclipse the terrible
failures of the emergency services on
the night
I do extend my thanks to the chair of
the inquiry so John unto his team
today's report has been a long time
coming it's very thorough
and whilst we'll need some time to
digest all the detail we accept the
findings in full
I want to repeatedly outset what the
mayor has said that great lines of fire
rescue service and greater Manchester
police that we have today are
unrecognizable from the organizations
the mayor and I inherited in 2017.
there have been two distinct phases of
transformation since then which have led
to these significant changes
firstly immediately after the arena
attack we knew we could not wait for
years for an official inquiry before the
families and the public have some
answers and that's why as the mayor said
we set up because like review which was
published in 2018.
under the framework of the greater
Manchester resilience Forum which I
began to attend personally
a robust process of implementation of
all occurs like recommendations was
begun and monitored closely
for example
the fire service made changes to the
nilo role the national interagency the
liaison officer role to ensure greater
communication and collaboration with
Partners including having an ILO
permanently co-located in the GMP Force
duty office during working hours with
communication channels in place for
direct contact at all other times
nylos are now automatically mobilized by
Northwest Fire Control to chemical
biological radiological nuclear or
explosive incidents and promoting
terrorist attacks mtas
it was clear on the night of the attack
that there was a failure of joint
working and in particular of the Jessup
principles The Joint emergency service
interoperability principles between all
three Emergency Services
principles stipulate that emergency
services should co-locate at the
earliest opportunity communicate
coordinate jointly assess and understand
the risk and have shared situational
awareness
a dedicated radio channel for Northwest
Fire Control GMP NYS and the other
partners control rooms was established
immediately after the arena attack
since then the system has evolved on the
current system the emergency service
interoperability control allows for
communication between control rooms
across the northwest
a great amount is a radio channel for
blue light commanders remains in place
both channels are regularly tested and
have been effectively used in
multi-agency incidents and exercises
since then
many multi-agency training exercises
have taken place to test Jessup and
Joint working between major incidents at
a local and City region level involving
all the emergency services and other
partners since the immuno attack
training has been embedded through
online and face-to-face training for all
operational offices and incident
commanders in gmfrs for example 194
officers have taken place in Jessup
trading and 17 try service training
sessions have taken place
the specific issues for GMP that Arabic
report for example the force duty
officer and the training of officers
have similarly been addressed the force
duty officer had too many demands on the
night and since the attack
Firearms role has been separated out
the force duty officer is now based at
GMP headquarters and in the event of an
incident Jesse principal was Far
implemented immediately such that the
force duty officer is fully supported at
headquarters and other emergency
services co-locate with them
the second phase of organizational
transformation subsequent to these
immediate and specific post attack
measures has been for both the police
and the fire service a fundamental
change in leadership culture
organization accountability governance
and Performance Management
the mayor's already referred to the fact
that many firefighters contacted both of
us with their concerns about leadership
and culture in the far service and that
we visited every fire station and
premises to make sure the voices of
officers and staff were being heard
we change the leadership appointed a new
interim G Fire officer and instituted a
wide-ranging program of change in every
area of organizational and operational
activity
following his appointment in 2020
on the Chief Fire officer David
Russell's leadership there has been a
sea change in the culture of the
organization
recognized by the Chief Inspector who
now judges the service to be good in
this area
with the Chief Fire officer the mayor
and I owes us that new priorities for
the fire service outlined and Via plan
and the service continues to make
improvements it needs
that has already spoken about
improvements to our MTA armed multi uh
my MTA capabilities I think your pardon
and every one of our firefighters is
receiving enhanced training on
specialist equipment will be available
on every fire engine so they can respond
quickly and effectively to a terrorist
attack while casualty incident
the training includes a practical
multi-agency Training Day with the blue
light partners and Northwest Fire
Control and is alignment of the police
handling services including joint
aggressive training exercises to test
our integrative response
and in September 2022 the Chief
Inspector removed the cause of concern
for MDA and was satisfied that the new
capability would provide a robust
response to any future terrorist
incident
in relation to GMP the substantive
failure of leadership by senior
commanders identified by the inquiry
report today is an indictment
but it's one that has already been
identified by Her Majesty's Chief
Inspector and we have acted to change
fundamentally the leadership culture and
performance across the board
two years ago the then she Constable was
asked to leave and Stephen Watson was
appointed last year
he began immediately defining the new
strategic direction to secure the
necessary improvements and building a
new senior officer team
Chief Inspector last week as you've
heard released GMP from special measures
in the light of a very significant
Improvement so far and that process of
change continues
I am confident that both GMP Amazon
are fundamentally different
organizations than they were in 2017.
Focus now on serving the public
effectively
on continuously improving their
performance
countable and transparent and with
outstanding leaders
there is no complacency here
we must now assess systematically the
recommendations of the inquiry report
against the measures we have already
taken
and ensure that all the outstanding
recommendations are implemented in for
as soon as possible
when we saw how the people operation
Manchester came together during our most
difficult time
demonstrated that exemplary Civic and
public response
stood together to show we were not going
to let the terrorists win then it's very
clear to us that they deserve nothing
but the best and that's what we will
strive for thank you
good evening
22nd of May 2017 in the dark and
harrowing day for our city and will
never be forgotten by anyone in
Rochester
today is another difficult day for
families with those lost the survivors
and for so many other people affected
and they remain in our thoughts although
today's report is not about the city
council I'm here alongside the bar of
the Deputy married to make a short
statement on behalf of the city as we
reflected in on that terrible day and
night and it's at aftermath
earlier this year we marked as the fifth
anniversary of the attack as we opened
the blade of light a permanent Memorial
honoring the 22 people whose lives were
so cruelly cut short
we also remember all those who were
injured many of whom are still living
with physical and mental impacts what
happened to this day
so John Saunders rightly reflected today
and we've heard it this evening on the
many examples of individual acts of
Bravery especially from the public on
that night it's right that they are
recognized and that they are remembered
what we know but for those most closely
affected by the events of that day
especially those who lost loved ones the
pain is still very wrong
the findings of the public inquiring
about how people were left down badly by
Emergency Services is the immediate
aftermath made for deeply distracted
reading
it's essential for those most closely
involved for the city and indeed for the
country that we go through this process
however painful to understand how events
unfolded that night
it will take some time to digest
different inquiry report in fill and
indeed its recommendations but it's
clear and we've heard repeatedly that
the response of emergency services and
that night simply not good enough and
that people deserve that
while it is only right that Services
have apologized it is vital then I set
out the options to have taken and Will
night it both individually and
collectively it means that things would
be different that they would be better
in the future
and we have heard some of those actions
already taken place today as it's been
set out throughout the course of the
afternoon
the report sets out a range of actions
for emergency services at the greater
Manchester Regional National level and
also options for the government
one such legislative change is the duty
to protect or March as well as we
thought in Manchester we've already
embedded these principles in our
licensing process the work of Staff
hundreds of promises who have had
counter terrorism training but this must
go further they must go faster than
urgently needs to be enshrined in love
to John and the inquiry will monitor
progress on the report's actions and on
behalf of the city and the city council
I will seek assurances that these
recommendations are and have been acting
upon
today's report is harrowing
Steve Phipps setting and it's
uncomfortable
but it's absolutely necessary
as it's imperative that actions are
taken to address feelings not just in
honor of those who lost their lives in
the 22nd of May 2017 for those who lives
will change forever but so no one has to
go through similar grief and Trauma in
the future
Manchester continues to support the
important work of the public inquiry as
it enters its final phase
and once again I would like to convey my
thanks
sister John and the inquiry team
but importantly and especially how a
heartfelt tribute to the incredible
families
incredible families have lots of walls
and survivors have painfully relived
their Darkest Hours to ensure a true
account retired and to inform
improvements for the future
future response that must be better and
above all my thoughts with those kills
families and those laughs and survivors
and those affected are one of the worst
days in our cities along history we will
never forget
thank you very much indeed we will never
forget and we will always support
the families into the future police it's
over to you to ask any questions to any
of us
Phil McCann for BBC Northwest tonight
and you talked about being misled by Ian
Hopkins
um he's saving his job of course as
Chief Constable for three years after
the attack I wonder if you feel that you
can and he couldn't hold him
and other Chief constables to account I
wonder if you feel betrayed by him and I
wonder if you regret keeping him in post
for so long
what this uh reveals today this report
is how difficult it can be
to challenge your police force if
they're the narrative that is coming up
is
is one that is not reflecting the
reality
and for myself and the deputy
neighborhood program this is that is the
narrative we were told
in the aftermath so it wasn't just to
cursely that was
that makes it very hard
because we didn't have evidence to
disprove that and in fact we'd set up
the curves like review
precisely for that purpose to provide
that independent
Assurance of whether or not what was
being said was was correct and it was
only as you've seen the report the very
final
days before the Kozak report was
published the things changed
so it makes
the job very difficult and that's why
um I have called for a duty of Canada
today I think that would make the job of
all police and crime Commissioners in
England and Wales easier
because if there was such a duty on
people at every level
of a police force I think the truth
would be established more quickly in the
aftermath of instance like this and then
in an arcades myself and steps in there
but others would be able to hold those
those senior people to account
so I think what comes through here is
that we didn't have the evidence in
relationship we had it in relation to
fire service
but we didn't have that clear picture in
relation to Greater Manchester police
and obviously a line was taken through
that process that goes like process
which in the end was not the correct uh
correct view
and it's that obfuscation that makes it
very hard for people in the position
that I and others are in and it's why
I've called for the change that I have
today
but obviously when I had the evidence I
did out
and that change was made
and Great Master police is a very
different police force today as a result
of that change
hi Kevin from Radio Manchester
on that so the duty of Canada is
essentially what what this would have
happened is the people up at the top
came up with a narrative which
essentially protected them so are you
saying that the duty Panda would be on
the lower levels so they would be
advised to speak out rather than keeping
the most shocked to protect the people
above them and and on that I mean the
chief chief Constable of police went
with a healthy pair nor down the boss of
the fire service went with a healthy
parent no doubt and people might be
watching this saying with all the
leaders saying lessons have been learned
thinking well
I'm sure people don't want to you don't
want to make it personal but there are
two high profile people at the top who
all of us are all these failures who
walked away with a healthy payout so is
there some regret from you that that was
allowed to happen
okay thanks for the answer both of those
questions if you want to come in as well
please do on the first question the duty
of Canada would apply corporately to a
an entity a police service or another
public body but it would also apply
individually on all uh people employed
by that by that service and
the reason why I believe this is so
profoundly important because this is a
pattern that has repeated through the
decades
is that
it would actually be a protection
to those people in the lower levels of
an organization because as I say it
would apply equally all the way down it
would be a protection for anything
chose to challenge a corporate narrative
or speak out
in a way that the organization might
find inconvenient that is what you need
in my experience if you want to get to
the truth of the first and earliest
opportunity and getting to the truth at
the first and earliest opportunity is
massively in the public interest because
it's at that point that an organization
can start to to learn and to then
improve
and I can only say from our experience
that it was when you act when you
finally can see the full picture and you
couldn't correctly say what's wrong with
the organization can actually start to
turn the corner and come back so I think
the duty of Canada is profoundly
important
it's five years today since well this
week that since it was recommended if it
really needs to move forward if the
government is serious about removing the
other forces from special
having a situation in this country where
career families are not re-traumatized
by the the false narratives and the
pushing away that they offer an
experience uh in the aftermath of events
like these on the second part of uh your
your question
as I just said a moment ago to Phil when
I had all the evidence I needed I acted
immediately
and in acting immediately I wanted to
make sure that I created the conditions
as quickly as possible
for the organization to begin to improve
and the clear advice I received is that
that will be better done by doing no
more I might say than honoring
contractual commitments so there was no
additional it was only the contractual
commitment that was in place if
I had tried to do more and reduce
contractual commitments then we would
have ended a probably a protracted legal
situation which could at the end of cost
more money so the clear advice I had
from the most senior officers in the
growth of combined Authority was to
honor the contractual commitment create
the change as quickly as possible and
then open up the circumstances in which
new leadership could come in and I would
say to you Kevin this evening
the greater Manchester police is the
quickest police horse out of special
measures because of the actions that are
in the deficit map that doesn't matter
Manchester United news and he said
repeatedly that the police and fire
service are sort of unrecognizable now
is how they were five years ago and
you've said about how close you are with
the families and how you've been working
so much with them over the last five
years and just how much confidence do
you have
that is a similar situation were to
happen today that GMP fire service could
in a different way than they did then
you know
probably as a
young reports
so thank you thank you
um
so I have made that point and the deputy
member at that point but in some ways
don't just take hard work for it look at
what his majesties
uh Chief Inspector was saying in
relation to both both services
um they are
assessed independently to be in a very
different a different place than they
than they were
on the um on the second part of your
question I would refer to what I heard
the chief Constable say in the previous
session
leadership I talk about leadership a lot
what is good leadership
good leadership is doing it directly
from the front
taking a grip of a situation
and I I'm pretty confident I heard the
chief Constable say today that he would
be the gold commander on a night
God forbid if we were to see then he
would be and everything comes from that
the most senior people taking
responsibility for a situation providing
the clarity then across the organization
that didn't happen in 2017 but I have no
doubt in my mind whatsoever
and I say this to the public approach
Manchester were there to be a repeat of
something similar I I have no doubt that
our chief counselor and our Chief Fire
officer will be in the same room within
a very short space of time they will
both be leading from the front and from
that
the officers providing CD leadership of
the scene and everybody else would have
absolute clarity as to what was expected
of them
I'll just answer that that you know
saying that we are confident that
different organizations now
we're not saying that but nothing could
go wrong in the future we can just leave
them to it because as the report itself
makes clear
um one of the significant failures was
that on the night
what people needed to do the application
for instance of the Justice principles
come together at a single place was not
embedded in in their psyche or in their
practice it should just kick in
automatically because it's been so well
rehearsed so well repeated in training
exercises it should just happen that is
what we have to keep doing as I said
that started as a really robust and
rigorous program now of interagency
sizes
we have to continue that so it's the job
of the mayor and I to make sure that
through the resilience forum and through
our holding our chief officers to
account we have evidence ourselves that
those exercises continue so that the
individual people in those services are
ready to respond in the right way should
they need to
any further questions
if not colleagues and a very long
afternoon thank you very much for
bearing those